Will lower tax lead to higher growth for lower
growth?
You know, it really depends what's the level
of tax you start from in what country and
it really depends what you do with your tax
revenue.
In Europe it's interesting because we have
28 different countries in the European Union
with very different level of taxation.
Now the countries with the lowest tax level,
countries like Bulgaria or Romania where the
total tax revenue is 20 or 30 percent GDP,
whereas the richest countries like Sweden
or Denmark have 50 percent of GDP in tax revenue.
So if it was enough to have low tax in order
to be rich then Bulgaria and Romania would
be richer than Sweden and Denmark and apparently
this is not working this way.
Probably because what Sweden and Denmark do
with their high tax revenue is to invest them
in education, in public infrastructure.
So if you do useful things with your tax revenue,
in fact it can be very good for growth and
you need public infrastructure, you need public
investment in education in order to grow.
Now of course, if you don't to do all these
good things with your tax revenue then higher
taxes can certainly be bad for growth.
So it all depends what you do with your tax.